a very strange sense of Terror that
comes from knowing exactly what's going
to happen to you there's a strange sense
of calm that comes from it also but in
the middle of the night when you can't
sleep sometimes you feel happy knowing
what they're trying to do to you and
sometimes you feel terrified knowing
what they're trying to do to you I'm
very happy every single podcast I did
previous to this I hammered the point
home and I made it very clear that I had
the intention of trying to put me in
jail I said there's three lives they try
and cancel you and slander you and
destroy your name they don't just want
you to disappear from the internet they
want to disappear from the internet in a
cloud of Shame they have to shame you
which is why they chose the crimes they
did for me and it's why they usually
choose the crimes they choose because
it's heinous they want to shame you and
they want you to Disappear With Your
Head facing the ground and never pop up
again